as we told you earlier in the show
democratic infighting a civil war is
intensifying tonight as the far left
radical progressive party is doubling
down they're saying no infrastructure
deal without the massive 3.5 trillion
reconciliation package to go along with
it they tried again to sneak amnesty in
it senator manchin west virginia fired
back at a statement today calling the
trillions in spending quote fiscal
insanity let's see if he holds a line
here to react to all of this he's the
author ten solid weeks in a row number
one on the new york times list american
marxism over a million copies sold the
million and a half in print he hosts
life liberty and levin right here on the
fox news channel number one in a slot
nationally syndicated radio show host
man
your introduction is getting too long
i just call them the great one thank me
god bless us how am i uh you know mark
we both have gone over this bill with a
fine tooth comb they even they even have
a mileage tax in this thing 2
465 pages
you know your book's called american
marxism
that's exactly what you warned about
this is exact and you have chapter 7
your last chapter over 10 000 words
it gives us the answer
how do you stop this
first of all i want people to know this
is what 2500 pages looks like that is in
one bill and i would ask the american
people do you have any idea what's in
this bill most of you don't because the
press isn't really telling you other
than a few platitudes sean what i would
like to hit on are the lies that we're
getting about the debt about the default
because the democrats and every one of
these debates tries to scare the hell
out of the american people we're going
to default on our debt says yelling the
treasury secretary
says the hacks around biden says nancy
pelosi we're not going to default on our
debt
let me go through this very quickly
and by the way i had to call it on my
radio show and said hey look if the 5.5
trillion dollars is all paid for at no
cost why are we raising the debt ceiling
anyway so in other words if the lie is
that this isn't going to cost us
anything it's all paid for why is there
even a debate
about raising the debt ceiling
the government won't default on that
service because that's what we're
talking about folks listen to me
carefully
the tax revenue continues we get about
320 billion dollars in a month the
federal government does all forms of
federal taxation and user fees
and yet the debt service is a little
over 44 billion dollars a month 320 44.
there is way more than enough to pay for
the debt service you've been hearing
democrats you've been hearing fools on
tv say things like this is to pay for
trump spending no it's not
raising the debt ceiling is for future
spending on future programs it's not for
past programs raising the debt ceiling
is about future spending
now also they talk about social security
the way it works is if we do not have an
increase in the debt ceiling
and you have 320 billion dollars coming
in the first amount of money is to pay
the debt service 44 bill
trillion 44 billion a month
then social security and medicare are
paid as a matter of federal statute
federal pensions are paid and then
beyond a few more then the politicians
have to work out the rest of which is
paid oh isn't that too bad they're only
getting four trillion dollars a year but
they want a lot more so i'm just making
the point that the debt that the the
credit on the debt the full faith and
credit of the united states cannot be
violated unless the treasury secretary
and the president do it purposely which
is a violation of federal law and the
federal constitution but here's what i
think the democrats are going to do
the democrats want to put in place the
most massive social engineering and
welfare state in world history they want
to turn your lives inside out and upside
down they want to draw all concentration
of power from you your family your faith
your county your town your state into
washington dc
so what are they going to do i think
they'll agree to lower the amount but
they'll still have all this stuff in
this 2500 page
bill
so that they can enshrine and put in
place these things they don't really
care about the debt
so people like manchin and perhaps
cinema can say see we lowered the amount
of money i hope that doesn't happen but
we'll see one other thing
democrats people in the media are saying
biden should act on his own under the
14th amendment we have so many
constitutional ignoramuses on tv it's
unbelievable the 14th amendment says the
validity that public debt of the united
states authorized by law including debts
incurred for payment of pensions and
bounties for services
uh in suppressing insurrection rebellion
shall not be questioned in other words
you have to pay the debt service this
doesn't give the power to the president
of the united states to take over the
power of the purse article one section a
clause see this is a smart audience this
is an msnbc this isn't cnn this isn't
the networks this is fox it says the
congress shall have power to lay and
collect taxes duties impose excises to
pay the debts and provide for the common
defense and general welfare of the
united states that's a core duty of
congress the next section says that
congress should have power to borrow
money on the credit of the united states
so when you have guys like clyburn and
others saying joe biden should just say
i can't let the united states uh default
on its the it's dead and
exercise the 14th amendment understand
these people are incredibly stupid
because again they're not going to
default on the debt social security will
be paid medicare will be paid the
pensions will be paid and what the
democrats really want is an open
checkbook to spend whatever they want
and to the republicans uh credit they've
said no now here's another example of
things that are going on real quick
betty mccauley points out there's
billions and billions of dollars in this
bill for these left-wing community
activist groups
this bill needs to be killed i don't
care what the cost is it needs to be
killed
you're supposed to say that's it i'm
done
thank me
i forgot
yes
[Laughter]
all right but don't forget watching
mark's show life liberty levin
sunday nights eight o'clock right here
on fox don't miss his radio show
weekdays six to nine easter hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else